The live-action adaptation of "The Little
Mermaid" has arrived and early reactions to
the film are largely positive. So why should
moviegoers want to be a part of its world?
Those who attended the premiere cite
the captivating performances and the
infectious musical numbers, led by Halle
Bailey as Ariel. Several lucky fans took
to Twitter to share their thoughts,
including an R & B icon who knows a
thing or two about making waves
with a powerful musical number.
Naturally, after a series of divisive live-action
Disney remakes, viewers are a bit apprehensive
about the upcoming release, particularly
about the too-realistic designs of beloved
characters like Flounder and Sebastian. But a
sample of early reactions should assure fans
that “The Little Mermaid” offers a faithful
adaptation of the classic animated film.
Strong performances in the 2023 version
reportedly drive the film and make it more
lively than other Disney live-action adaptations.
Viewers fortunate enough to catch the film early
single out Melissa McCarthy's portrayal of
the devious sea witch Ursula and Daveed Diggs'
lively singing as Sebastian, in addition
to Bailey's impressive depiction of Ariel.
"I've been watching you for a long time, dearie."
When Things Go Pop writer
Brandon Lewis wrote on Twitter,
"I was blown away by ["The Little Mermaid"]. Some
visual issues aside, it's the most romantic and,
dare I say, magical Disney has been in years.
The best live-action remake by a mile. Daveed
Diggs is the MVP. Halle Bailey is a superstar,
and her 'Part of Your World' is a showstopper."
In addition to the heartfelt performances,
many are looking forward to the show-stopping
musical numbers that made the original film
such a cherished Disney classic. So far,
many early reactions claim that
"The Little Mermaid" lives up to
expectations and accurately recreates
what made the original so special.
Meanwhile, Discussing Film writer A. Felicia
Wade still loved the film despite
some slight criticisms, posting,
"["The Little Mermaid"] makes it pretty close to
being the best live action Disney movie, however
it still struggles in the villain department.
Halle Bailey IS Ariel and I had literal chills
throughout her performance. This is a little
mermaid retelling like you've never seen before."
These promising reactions should sooth worried
fans who may be apprehensive about the new remake.
Music is, of course, still a major part of this
live-action "The Little Mermaid," and it still
grounds Ariel's narrative as she travels on
her journey of self-discovery. Thankfully,
the 2023 remake reportedly nails this part of the
film, thanks to the talented cast led by Bailey,
one half of the musical duo Chloe x Halle. Kelly
Rowland of Destiny's Child fame posted on Twitter,
"The Little Mermaid is truly
AN EPIC WATCH!!! The music in
this movie!! FREAKINGGGGGGGWOWWWWW!! You laugh,
you cry, you'll sing along!! I know I'm gonna
be singing these songs for weeks to come!!!!!!"
Given her girl group bonafides,
this is major praise for the music in
Disney's latest live-action remake.
Several early reactions can't say enough good
things about Bailey's performance as Ariel,
but there's also plenty of love out
there already for the film's villain.
Illuminerdi writer Stephanie Ramirez tweeted,
"["The Little Mermaid"] was an
ABSOLUTE gem! Halle Bailey IS Ariel,
no matter what anyone says. She brings in the
charm and personality of Ariel to life. Melissa
McCarthy as Ursula was just *chef kiss*.
This film was such a joy to experience."
This was echoed by Fandango writer
Erik Davis, who posted that he also
got chills from Bailey's performance,
and labeled McCarthy a "scene stealer."
It seems like "The Little Mermaid" will make a
sizable splash when it swims
into theaters on May 24th.